gilles bernès parisien se serait combien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vendeur mais c'est vrai qu'on bien lu
par exemple non mais non mais alors là
je sais pas non mais comme on dit ah oui
la ned - peut-être peut-être moins de 10
peut-être peut-être peut-être heures est
ce que site au même niveau que j'étais
là on est extrêmement mal à moins de 10
peut-être un peu moins de 10 jours quoi
bâtiments non mais peut-être moins de 10
mais parce qu'après en dessous de 10 je
peux plus dire parce qu'après c'est
compliqué c'est la marge d'erreur
bernard montiel des vexations mais alors
bernard mendy oui voilà c'est dans ces
catégories
non sans penser à sa femme bien sûr
oui non non non alors d'ailleurs dans
les couloirs j'ai demandé à benjamin
qu'est ce qui le faisait parce que je le
trouve de plus en plus beau et de plus
en plus et je vais
au
dessus guillaume on parlera on est dans
un monde idéal plus personne et avec
personnes est parti loin de tout ça lui
a pris la moitié de sa nouvelle
mais c'est vers elle a pris la moitié ça
non fortune il est tranquille il est
célibataire toi toi nono aussi
roger truc il est loin de tout ça non
mais non mais clairement guillaume et
non ce soir le benjamin est au dessus du
panier
avec elle panique on n'est pas un pique
nique
elle n'a pas du tout parce que tu as eu
des pressions n'ont ni dépression je
retiens ma pression mais c'était pour
protéger mes collections mais ne protège
pas du tout c'est ne t'inquiète pas tu
sais il
va se protéger
alors lorsqu'il a vu this question mais
ce qu'obama est à plus de 10 non non il
est en dessous de guillaume mais ils au
dessus des autres oui voilà quand il ya
une très belle peau voilà ça sert temps
là tu vois tu as une belle peau tu vois
non mais c'est vrai que je tape à dieu
mais tu as une belle quoi ces derniers
jours j'ai réfléchi vraiment un truc et
je sais pas si certaines filles ici
présente même ou femme voilà dans le
public pense pareil ça va vous passez la
même maladie que ce
qui se passe en ce moment je pense que
si un jour je ne suis plus en couple
avec roger je pense peut-être même que
je me dirigerai vers une femme oui non
ça tombe bien j'ai une chatte
[Applaudissements]
je rigole d'amer alors je veux j'ai vu
guillaume tout dit j'ai vu deux hommes
de
sachets sachez qu'il a tout prix de sa
mère
[Applaudissements]
avec cette déclaration delphine vous
êtes ambitieux alors moi mais elle fait
alors moi delphine je vais vous dire
pour moi delphine et jeu elle le sait
enfin il est fini pour moi que tu as et
que je suis vraiment non mais vraiment
et je l'adorais bien mais on avait dit
le ca pourtant les défraiements et on le
sait tous les vrais modèles clean c'est
vraiment voilà c'est sexy finale à bois
c'est épais
10h53 les magnifiques arrêts magnifiques
mais c'est pas en plus c'est elle pour
moi je pense tellement à guillaume et
oui c'est massa nous sont guillaume séné
sont pas ce que je retiens c'est que je
sus du panier bien sur mac delphine se
positionne sur moi ça fait deux ans que
je m'interdis toute relation à huy alors
ça c'est bon on a des attentes mais vous
vous êtes en attendre mes bottes que
kate beaucoup moins
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est ça en fait j'ai pas compris la
belgique donc delphine on a on a fait le
bilan ouais % ou est ce que je pourrais
juste vendée aux personnes qui sont là
les femmes de lever la main celles qui
pensent comme moi n'ont certes on est
sans arrêt ça mais je voudrais des rames
après les jeunes qui étaient en train de
devenir folle
personne apparemment bas de l'échelle
sont venus avec leur mac et son envie de
repartir avec elle avec lui merci en
tout cas d'un film pour cette révélation
louis brouillard qui est pas venu depuis
longtemps et je suis sûr de ne pas avoir
été cité dans la sphère un jeu peut être
moins de dix mois
que toi c'est vrai que je vais pas
demander à me positionne quand même
marié truchet l'antirouille l'asadho
rien dire
alors je te le dis il lundi de plus de
et l'autre qui fait
tout cela alors oui j'ai plusieurs
points des plusieurs principes et pas
avec plus jeune que moi d'accord avec
plus vieille que moi à oui on m'a très
bien merci oui c'est bien parce que
quand on prend une banane comme l'a si
bien dit
[Applaudissements]
what else akwaya partie directe